anyone up for a little air icebreakers
you know I once did trust fools of Barry
Diller and it was the beginning of a
lifelong friendship and then once we
trust each other then we can discuss
making a deal for fake Eleanor this
sucks
how do you guys eat without listening to
hardcore porn oh come on this is the
good place you can do anything you want
what about throwing a rager and totally
trashing this place oh yeah I've been to
that we could totally go to town oh no I
actually did that party
[Music]
one of them no thank you I don't use
cocaine oh it's not cocaine idiot we're
snorting time sorry you'll snorting the
concept of time yeah I don't forth you
up yo monk dude you know how to tap a
keg deta baby what do you want to do
okay i'm mussolini speech oh the Mel
Gibson rant that's a classic awesome ooh
let's do the Nixon tapes that's my jam
what you always have to remember the
Irish is they get mean virtually every
Irish I've known gets mean when he
drinks tell them to stop oh I think I
made it pretty clear that I don't
approve damn you got it it's about damn
time that the Jew in America realizes
he's an American first and a Jew second
Oh - honey I'm so sorry I will obviously
clean all of this up I don't care about
the house Michael I'm just upset that
you let them walk all over you I know
they're the only thing in the universe
that scares me I know what I have to do
I just have to be more accommodating
offer them everything they want given to
all of their demands and then they'll
have to respect me
no you need to stand up for yourself I'm
going to tell you the same thing that I
told Marx look about right before he
outed Eduardo Saverin you are smart
you are capable and the time has come to
hit unfriend I also told Marc to lose
the the just Facebook that was meat
you